في السعوديه بدات الهيئه العامه للاحصاء
تنفيذ المسح الصحي الوطني 2023 لتوفير
بيانات حول صحه السكان والخدمات الصحيه
الايات التاسعه من خلال المسح الذي من
المقرر ان يستمر حتى 27 من الشهر الجاري
الى ايجاد قاعده بيانات موثوقه لدعم
المنظمات المحليه والاقليميه والدوليه
ودعم تطوير التنافسيه السعوديه في المجال
الصحي ومراقبه التقييم والتنفيذ البرامج
الصحيه فضلا عن العمل على التحسين الحاله
الصحيه والتعزيز الخدمات في القطاع
في الاستوديو ينضم الينا الكاتب والاخصائي
الاجتماعي محمد الحمزه سيد محمد حياك الله
معي
ما هو المسح الصحي الوطني ما هي اهدافه
ولما باختصار لغه الارقام هي اللغه
العلميه الحقيقيه التي يبنى عليها حاليا
كل اتخاذ القرارات والانظمه والتشريعات
بالاضافه الى ان المنظمات الدوليه في
المؤشرات الدوليه هي تعتمد على لغه
الارقام لا تعتمد على اللغه الاخباريه او
على فقط ما يظهر من تقارير كلها اطار نظري
مكتوب فكان لا بد من ايجاد وسيله علميه
منظمه ومرتبه لاخراج ارقام بطريقه صحيحه
الهيئه الوطنيه للاحصاء ممثله او تحت
اشراف وزاره التخطيط هي الهيئه السعوديه
التي لديها القدره الهائله والمنظمه
ولديها الكوادر العلميه ولديها الاجهزه
التي تستطيع القيام بمثل هذه المسوحات
الوطنيه قبل فتره مثلا في عام 2010 استاذ
خالد كان هناك وطني للصحه النفسيه اوكي
جميل ورائع لكن ما زال ممتد حتى الان لم
ينتهي صحيح انه في مراحل الاخيره لكن لانه
كان تحت منظمه تكون شبه مستقله منظمه
بحثيه سعوديه تحت اشراف جامعه عالميه لكن
من خلال تجاربنا السابقه مع كل المسوحات
التي تقوم بها هيئه الاحصاء نجد ان المده
لا تكاد تاخذ من ست شهور الى سنه لاظهار
النتائج وفي البدايات لاحظنا خلال الفترات
الماضيه ان هناك بعض النتائج تبدا تظهر
بشكل تدريجي بشكل تدريجي ومهم جدا النقطه
المهمه في سؤالك يا استاذي الكريم ايش
الفائده من هذه الموسوحات حنا نتخذ قرارات
مبنيه على الارقام الصادره وللعلم فكره
الصحه في هذا المسح تعتمد على ثلاثه اشياء
مهمه وفقا لتعريف منظمه الصحه العالميه
احنا نتكلم عن الصح الجسديه الصح النفسيه
الصحه الاجتماعيه فلا فثلاثه اشياء ومح
مهمه جدا في رفع مستوى جوده حياه الناس
ولو تلحظ في كثير من الجهات الحكوميه الان
جلست ترتب نشاطاته ومشاريع وبرامج كلها
تعتمد على المعلومات الاحصائيه التي
تصدرها هيئه الاحصاء التي كانت تعتبر
بسيطه ولكنها الى حد ما مرضيه تعطينا الى
حد ما هذا المؤشرات اللي تخلينا نحدد الى
وين نبغى نتجه يعني نعطيك مثال بسيط جدا
فكره مرض الاكتئاب اللي الكل الان يشتكي
منه بالاحصاء بالارقام وجد ان مرض
الاكتئاب يصيب الشباب ما قبل سن ال 24
واذا لم يعالج سيمتد معهم بقيه حياتهم
لاحظت كيف الاحصائيات
والكثير ما يعرف اذن معناته اني لابد
اشتغل على برامج توعيه على برامج صحيه من
فتره المتوسط الثانوي فتره الجامعه لان
هذه الفتره مهمه جدا في تحقيق التوازن
النفسي
تتكلم العمليه الان طبعا انت قاعد تتكلم
عن اذا تقصد المسح الاقليه الوطني حتما
سيكون بالتعاون مع اكثر من جهه فهو لا يخص
وزاره الصحه فقط ولا يخص المركز الوطني
للصحه النفسيه ولا يخص حتى وزاره الموارد
البشريه والتنميه الاجتماعيه انت تتكلم عن
منظومه متكامله تعمل معها هيئه الاحصاء
لاخراج النتائج بالطريقه التي نريد الوصول
لها بالاضافه وهذه نقطه مره مهمه انت
تتكلم عن خطه علميه مبنيه على اصول علميه
لاخراج هل بيتصلوا علينا مثلا يسالونا عن
الحاله النفسيه والحاله الصحيه
وفود من وزاره الصحه تعمل تحاليل بس حتى
نعرف طبعا حددت عينه عينه ممثله للشعب
السعودي انت تتكلم عدد السعوديين تقريبا
انت تتكلم في الخمسه وثلاثين مليون فالعين
التقريبيه وفقا لبعض النظريات في الميه هم
اربعه الاف محدده او على مستوى
على مستوى مناطق ومحافظات المملكه في
الوصول الى 4000
وسؤالهم اسئله مقننه ومدروسه واسئله علميه
امر سهل جدا الجلسه الاحصائيه لا تاخذ سوى
45 دقيقه وفقا للتدريب الذي حصل عليه
الباحثين والاحصائيين اللي بيجمعون
المعلومات طبعا هناك خطه احصائيه للذهاب
الى كل منطقه الى الدخول الى عدد معين من
الاسر وسؤالهم هذه الاسئله اسئله طبعا هي
اسئله تعطيك المؤشرات انا في الاخير في
احد ما هو عارف مثلا انه في مرض معينه
ومشكله معينه
الان ممكن ما تعطيك نتيجه صحيح انت تتكلم
ليس المساله الان مساله رصد بالدقه يعني
بشيء دقيق جدا انت تاخذ بشكل عام كمؤشرات
انت لو تاخذ الان بالذات المملكه انت
تتكلم عن مناطق متراميه الاطراف عن نتكلم
عن قرى في اقصى الجنوب واقصى الشمال
وتتكلم عن مدن عن مدن كبيره مثل طبعا احنا
نتكلم عن نمط الغذاء نتكلم عن نمط الرياضه
والحياه نتكلم عن طبيعه الادويه اللي
الانسان يستخدمها حتى لو بدون وصفه طبيه
وعليها قصداني يعني حنا نعرف انه في كثير
من المناطق حتى بعضنا هنا في المملكه انه
قد يعتمدون على الطب البديل اكثر من
اعتمادهم مثلا على الطب العلمي الصحيح طيب
هذه اشكاليه مع مرور الزمن وفي هذا الوقت
اللي يفترض ان نسبه التعليم تكون في عاليه
طيب نبغى نشوف ليش هذه الاسباب قد تكون
بسبب بعد المراكز الطبيه قد تكون بسبب
الثقافه حتى المجال الاعلامي الصحي يدخل
هنا في محاوله كشف ومعرفه كيف ممكن نقدر
نخدم البلد وبعدين تمت العمليه اجري هذا
المسح كيف بيكون انعكاساته على الحاله
الجسديه على امكانات الصحيه المطلوبه في
بعض المناطق على
الامور النفسيه على الامور الاجتماعيه في
المتوقع وشو اللي بيتغير بصفه عامه كنظره
الانسانيه للبشريه قاعدين نلحظ انه مستوى
اعمار الناس قاعده تزداد بسبب جوده الحياه
الصحيه هذا على مستوى العالم فما بالك
بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه التي
تسعى حاليا وفق برنامج جوده الحياه الى
رفع مستوى حياه الناس الى جعلهم في وضع
مستقر وجعله في وضع متوازن اذا كنا نتكلم
يا استاذ خالد حتى عن الصحه النفسيه
والصحه بصفه عامه في داخل بيئات العمل
قاعدين نشوف الان جزء كبير جدا من المنشات
الصناعيه والصحيه قاعدين يحتم منشات
الصناعيه والحكوميه يوجد فيها حتى عيادات
طبيه يوجد فيها عيادات حتى نفسيه حتى مرشد
قد يكون حتى لو كان داخل اداره الموارد
البشريه هو لمحاوله حلول او ايجاد حلول
للناس لمختلف مشاكل يعطيك العافيه شكرا لك
محمد الحمزه الكاتب الاخصائي الاجتماعي
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات